[Musique]
bonjour et merci de nous rejoindre sur
tv soixante dix huit pour une nouvelle
édition du 7 8 politique voici les
titres de ce mois d'avril les annonces
du président reportée après l'incendié
de la cathédrale notre dame de paris les
élus notamment les mères n'en demeure
pas moins impatients d'entendre les
décisions qui marqueront la fin du
quinquennat les maires d'ile-de-france
qui viennent justement de tenir leur
salon annuel à la villette nous y étions
le scrutin des européennes ce sera le 26
mai en france quelles sont les
propositions des candidats est les
réponses aujourd'hui de françois-xavier
bellamy tête de liste des républicains
et de benoît hamon tête de liste
génération
et puis invité de cette émission
mustapha larbaoui pharmaciens ancien
président du club de football local
fondateur d'association à trappes
il a décidé de franchir le pas et de
s'engager en politique il sera candidat
aux municipales en 2020 elle mais sur
quelle liste
éléments de réponse en seconde partie
l'élection européenne se déroulera donc
le dimanche 26 mais d'ici là nous vous
proposons de suivre la campagne dans les
yvelines sur notre antenne mais aussi
est d'aller à la rencontre des candidats
pour débuter à la parole est à
françois-xavier bellamy tête de liste
républicain également élu à versailles
[Musique]
nous sommes la seule liste qui je crois
défendre ce que les français veulent
pour l'europe c'est à dire nous savons
que l'europe est nécessaire pour relever
les grands défis qui nous attendent pour
demain mais nous savons aussi que pour
que l'europe soit efficace au service de
notre destin il faut changer en
profondeur la manière dont elle se
construit
[Musique]
nous nous croyons à une europe qui
respecte la souveraineté la culture des
peuples nous croyons à une europe qui
trouve son juste modèle ni celui d'un
éparpillement de nations qui se font la
guerre ni non plus celui d'un empire qui
viendraient uniformiser tout sous une
forme de direction centralisée qui ne
pourrait être que technocratique nous
croyons que l'europe se réconciliera
avec les citoyens quand elle reviendra
au contact du terrain quand nous
pourrons ensemble sur les questions
d'agriculture d'économie d'énergie sur
les questions migratoires faire ensemble
de l'europe le lieu d'une coopération
efficace au service de nos démocraties
[Musique]
nous restons fidèles à notre position
nous continuons de défendre ce que nous
avons toujours défendu au fond on voit
bien que dans cette élection aussi bien
un monsieur macron comme madame le pen
change de discours pour pouvoir
convaincre les électeurs
il ne faut pas se laisser abuser par des
changements stratégiques nous nous
croyons à la constance à la cohérence à
la clarté nous savons qu'il faut sans
doute ajuster modifiez transformez
certaines choses nous croyons que cette
europe que nous pouvons construire
ensemble que notre famille politique
peut construire au sein du parlement
européen de demain
le croyant qu'elle peut refaire la
preuve de son efficacité
[Musique]
et en fin d'émission vous entendrez
benoît hamon le conseiller régional
d'ile-de-france et tête de liste de son
parti de sa nouvelle formation et
génération là trois jours consacrés aux
élus des communes franciliennes le salon
des maires d'ile-de-france 2019 se
tenait à mi-avril à la ville est un
événement organisé par l'association des
maires d'île de france dans un contexte
social particulier pour les
collectivités locales alors que le
président de la république doit toujours
faire des annonces suite au grand débat
national nicolas landry et patrick
jacques de dixmude un contexte
particulier pour l'ouverture du salon
des maires d'île de france 2010 9
difficultés quotidiennes des communes et
crise sociale des gis les jeunes le
président de la république doit faire
des annonces suite au grand débat
national et les maires franciliens ont
des attentes
il ya manifestement des réformes à faire
on peut pas rester avec un mille feuille
territorial qui ne fait que coûte et aux
citoyens et dont les citoyens ne veulent
plus par qui ne se reconnaissent plus
on nous annonce vraiment une
anticipation de la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation
beaucoup plus tôt que ce qui était prévu
puisque normalement c'était pour la fin
du mandat
sauf qu'on ne sait pas trop comment
financièrement ceux ci va être compensé
au niveau des villes mais je crois quand
même en faut changer de logiciel pour le
pilotage de la france quel que soit les
mandats c'est vrai du mandat numéro si
demain on veut des gens encore plus
compétents avec stéphane bonnet maire d
evry courcouronnes la nouvelle la
commune nouvelle et président de
l'association des maires d'île de france
alors dans quel état d'esprit sont les
maires franciliens d'abord ils sont
toujours constructif et combatifs ils
sont pas abattus
ils n'ont pas encore abandonné le navire
jusqu'à pour une grande majorité d'entre
eux non on est au moment d'abord du
bilan delà de ce mandat puisque c'est le
dernier salon avant la fin du mandat
on est aussi au bilan du coup on débat
et de l' affaire dite des gilet jaune
avec des cahiers de doléances que montré
une profonde défiance du peuple à
l'endroit dans les gares notamment du
pouvoir central
mais une forte demande en même temps de
renforcement du pouvoir local et donc du
coup après avoir été vilipendé et
traiter de clientéliste on voit que les
maires reviennent au coeur du débat et
redevienne nécessité dès lors qu'il
s'agit de retisser le lien social avec
les habitants donc on est dans cet état
d'esprit constructif et puis pour la
construction et la réinvention du modèle
communal de demain la décentralisation
elle a commencé dans les années 80
un premier acte ensuite un second tact
dans au début des années 2000 ça c'est
comment s'adapter
oui oui je crois que c'est le c'est le
moment de l'acte iii se pose toujours la
question évidemment du millefeuille
institutionnel se poussent toujours la
question même si on enlevait la clause
de compétence générale aux départements
et aux régions du fait que beaucoup de
collectivités font la même chose et
dépensent de l'argent inutilement on
sait plus qui fait quoi et qui fait
voilà et puis de toute façon se pose
quand même la question des relations de
confiance et démocratique avec les
habitants et ça c'est les maires qui
l'ont pas le seul élu apprécié des
français ça reste le maire
c'est le seul qui est encore qui est
encore reconnue si on ne renforce pas
celui là si on ne renforce pas la
collectivité locale alors on ne
réformera jamais ce pays présente aussi
à l'ouverture de ce salon la ministre de
la cohésion des territoires jacqueline
gourault et la présidente de la région
ile de france valérie pécresse chacune
ont défendu leur modèle de réforme de la
décentralisation une fois que ces
décentralisée il faut que les
collectivités territoriales ont faux
prennent leurs responsabilités c'est le
mot du président de la république
jusqu'au bout des compétences parce que
souvent on est encore dans un système où
l'état a un goût des compétences les
collectivités à notre bout alors il faut
certainement clarifier cela
moi je crois qu'il faut que le président
de la république comprenne que les
territoires et les élus et bien sont au
plus près des préoccupations des
français et qu'il faut décentraliser on
en a assez de la technostructure qui
doublonnent qui complexifie qui empêche
qui interdit des échanges et des
rencontres avec leurs partenaires privés
et publics les maires partagent aussi
leurs expériences ce salon le dernier de
leur mandat avant les élections
municipales de 2020
le 7-8 politique de ce mois d'avril se
poursuit avec un retour sur la création
de l'association et lee hee lee pour élu
local des yvelines martha de sidrac
sénatrice en est à l'origine les
explications les yvelines sont le
département qui compte le moins de
femmes mères dans la région sonia breux
au maire de saint cyr l'école et à néry
le pallec maire de cheuvreux sont des
exceptions
elles font partie de l'association elie
lancé ce matin dans le but de promouvoir
les femmes dans les yvelines qui
désirent s'investir pour le territoire
nous vraiment ce qu'on voudrait faire
partager c'est notre expérience de femme
et lui faire profiter des femmes qui
souhaiteraient s'engager qui ont des
hésitations des questions des
interrogations leur montrer que c'est
possible je reste persuadé que le femmes
et un homme sont complémentaires
la housse je me pose question c'est sur
le le fait de devoir le l'imposer pour
que ça devienne effectif face à ce
manque de femmes dans les effectifs des
exécutifs locaux comme à l'échelle
nationale la sénatrice martha de sidra
qu'a lancé elie l'association de
promotion des femmes en politique dans
les yvelines
c'est tout simplement de permettre aux
femmes dose est d'aller plus loin dans
leurs ambitions parce que les femmes ont
également des ambitions et l'y
accompagnera également les élus dans
leur mandat et proposera à ses adhérents
des rencontres et des formations autour
des mandats politiques
on est toujours aux liens parce que
l'idée c'est de créer du réseau l'idée
c'est de créer du lien
cette association est également ouverte
aux hommes interpelle la secrétaire de
la délégation aux droits des femmes et à
l'égalité des chances entre les hommes
et les femmes
messieurs nous sommes à vos côtés et
nous avons montant de légitimité que
vous a aussi un moment donné nous saisir
de cet espace public
la cotisation à l'association elie et
d'un montant de 25 euros et les yvelines
compte une élue de moi puis en cour
commune de saint quentin en yvelines
n'est dorénavant plus administré par
marie-christine le tarnec cette dernière
est lui en 2016 après le départ de
françois de ligné et quitte à son tour
le poste elle évoque dans un courrier
adressé aux habitants aient des
problèmes de santé
même si elle ne devrait en revanche pas
quitter son poste au sein de
l'agglomération marie-christine le
tarnec qu'il n'a pas souhaité s exprimer
devant les caméras mais françois morton
son premier adjoint
elle devrait prendre la tête de la
commune prochainement écouter notamment
la réaction du président de saint
quentin en yvelines jean michel fourgous
on ne peut que bien sûr elle a félicité
de son courage là dessus et
deuxièmement elle m'a dit simplement que
le souvenir qu'elle avait en fait
qu'elle gardait de notre travail en
commun ce qui elle m'a dit est trois
mots je dirais confiance j'ai fait
confiance je suis quand même donné une
vice-présidence c'est quand même on
avait des différences qu'elle convoque
ans mais globalement elle me dit voilà
on s'est fait confiance en deuxièmement
elle me dit respect aussi
on respecte on
on respecte les gens
en dirigeant et c'est appréciable et
troisièmement elle m'a dit humour aussi
nombreux et trois mots et
confiance respect et humour ben voilà ce
qui résume nôtres
notre mandat nous restons dans
l'actualité politique locale avec
mustapha larbaoui bonjour bonjour vous
êtes trappistes pharmacien de profession
président d'honneur du club de football
de trappes fondateur de l'association
pharma citoyen qui a notamment à son
actif une sorte d'école de commerce on
en a déjà parlé sur cette antenne ou des
cours sont dispensés gratuitement pour
les pour les jeunes de la commune pas
seulement à 58 ans vous avez décidé de
vous lancer dans la campagne des
municipales de 2020 alors après tout ce
que j'ai cités comme actions menées sur
cette commune pourquoi maintenant
vouloir briguer la mairie de la commune
c'est une évolution normale
en fait c'est un cheminement auxquels je
me suis donc je me suis même pas aperçus
moi même souvent on me disait pourquoi
pas la politique et j'ai toujours refusé
de rentrer soit dans un parti politique
pour lesquels j'ai beaucoup de respect
aux par ailleurs par ailleurs mais je
suis pas rentré en politique je n'ai pas
fait un cheminement politique mais je
suis arrivé au bout d'un processus où ou
par le biais des associatifs
on a mené des actions très concrètes des
actions de terrain et je me suis rendu
compte que j'étais un peu entravé on va
dire essentiellement parlée le peu de
moyens dont on peut disposer parce que
c'est essentiellement des moyens
personnels avec quelques quelques
subventions et j'ai pensé qu'on pouvait
développer d'autres formes de
militantisme et en même temps rentrer
dans une structure communale pour avoir
un effet levier sur les sur les actions
c'est pas suffisant l'action que vous
veniez jusqu'à présent en tout cas voilà
vous aviez les mains liées quelques fois
vous ne publiez pas aller aussi loin que
vous l'auriez souhaité avec la en
passant de l'autre côté analyses ont
permis à delhi l'académie appelé comme
ça
renfort maths français pour des cm1 cm2
j'ai une classe j'aurais souhaité en
faire 7
c'est compliqué j'ai pas les moyens à ma
disposition en tous les cas les les
installations donc les salles les
budgets c'est presque pas le sujet une
concurrente s'est payé un goûter aux
enfants tous les jours
le ramassage par bus est assuré par une
société que je trouve extrêmement
citoyenne les cars périer par exemple un
autre ce type de partenariat ça profite
à trop peu
deux mondes et voilà un exemple l'école
de commerce qu'on a pompeusement appelé
comme ça bien sûr meilleur mot paul sont
promo paul par elle une dizaine
d'étudiants de 18 à 25 ans niveau bac
seulement
mais voilà pour aller beaucoup plus loin
on va faire un voyage d'étude au parent
à 8 sur sur le parlement européen
voilà donc ça reste des actions qui sont
de ce que j'entends extrêmement
sollicités extrêmement bien vu mais je
pense qu'on peut faire beaucoup mieux
sur ces domaines là bien sûr par l'effet
levier qui aurait que les moyens les
moyens communaux
mais pour le coup pour d'autres sujets
par exemple je suis pharmacien vous
l'avez dit tout ça voulait tout à
l'heure la désertification médicale
je me suis donc c'est moi même dans des
actions pour essayer de limiter la casse
il existe maintenant la télémédecine
donc je me suis engagé dans la
télémédecine sur ce sujet pareil ce sont
des éléments sur lesquels on peut
travailler au sein d'une commune avec
tous les habitants
donc il ya plein de sujets comme ça
autour du sport outre la culture elle
avait déjà un programme qui est
construit à présenter aux habitants
en l'occurrence que ce que j'ai déjà
fait c'est visible il ya un bilan dont
sur lequel on peut s'appuyer on va
parler du foot tout à l'heure n'a parlé
du ou par le phare mais si on parle de
l'éducation et la scolarité en
particulier oui alors il s'agira
maintenant d'aller voir les trappistes
pour savoir de quel autre sujet il
faudrait qu'on compare donc s'associer
mais je suis vraiment dans une démarche
pour le coup maintenant d'aller
rencontrer les habitants
il est ça m'est tombé dessus calvet vous
avez lancé une association pour ça pour
aller à la rencontre des trappistes et
écouter aussi leur retour sur un plan
purement politique ce qui n'est pas
encore décidée en revanche c'est le fait
de mener seule une liste d'être tête de
liste très clairement et de briguer le
poste de maire ou d'être associé à un
autre candidat
c'est en pleine réflexion oui c'est
d'autant plus qu'il vous proposera la
meilleure place sa liste alors non
puisque la place en k2 en cas de
rapprochement
je laisse ou était gelée décidé en
l'occurrence donc si elle m'est refusé
pour le coup je ne rentrerai pas mais je
veux viennent en tête de liste je pense
que j'ai des choses à porter je pense
que l'âge aidant le parcours et dans le
bilan est dans et puis il ya un
enthousiasme autour de lancement de
cette candidature il ya un vrai
enthousiasme je l'entends je le rock jeu
le recueil au quotidien sur le terrain
donc la tête de liste m'intéresse
simplement c'est pas une affaire
personnelle c'est long une affaire
collective si je pense que ma place
serait au sein d'une liste alors je le
ferai sachant que même sur la
rémunération par exemple je me suis
engagé à reverser aux associations ce
que je pouvais tout fait c'est pas du
tout ni une question d'argent ni une
question de comment dire de briguer une
place ou un poste à titre personnel mais
c'est parce que j'ai vraiment alors pour
le coup vraiment envie de bosser
continuer à bosser pour la commune j'ai
été accueilli par cette commune et ça
c'est très touchant
c'est quelque chose que qui vaut à elle
c'est quelque chose qui me portent donc
servir voilà c'est tout ce qui
m'intéresse en tête de liste bah
pourquoi pas si vraiment il faut y aller
en tout cas numéro 9 mai au moins au
moins un premier adjoint ont elles pour
mener quand même sur des dossiers très
importants
et pour pour tout pour être honnête avec
vous je commence à rencontrer les uns
les autres
ça se passe plutôt bien et je tiens à le
dire
j'espère que la vie démocratique va
continuer en ce sens on se parle
ça me paraît quand même quelque chose
d'important souvent white cloud it et
avec l'autre on me voit et claude on me
dit qu'avec la non on discute avec tout
le monde et c'est elle qui m'intéresse
on peut vous retrouver sur n'importe
quelle liste question pas de droite
comme de gauche on peut me retrouver sur
une liste où ce que j'ai a proposé sera
intégrée et bien évidemment mis en eux
ce soit un candidat de droite
divers droite voire républicain où un
candidat républican marche ou un
candidat socialiste comme un candidat
génération veulent l'être parce qu'il y
ait plusieurs oui absolue déjà comme la
turquie se manifestent tient lieu parce
que je me suis pas positionner sur
l'échiquier politique on connaît ma
sensibilité depuis depuis toujours qui
est une sensibilité de gauche the lady
est maintenant je préfère le dire
autrement g&g comment dire un
consentement à l'impôt à l'infini et je
participe financièrement à la
collectivité est également en temps en
temps en temps
en tant lendemain de mon temps mais
cette sensibilité c'est ce qui fait ma
personnalité
c'est ce qu'ils font de mes actions mais
pour le coup je sais qu'il ya un champ
républicain non chez tous
je proposerai une espèce de chartes des
points sur lequel je voudrais vraiment
pouvoir travailler j'ai parlé de
rééducation j'ai parlé donc de l'école
j'ai parlé du sport j'ai parlé de la
santé voilà est-ce que ces marques et
franchement à droite ou à gauche
probablement qu'il y aura un débat
seront l'imposition il est plus un
marqueur de droite ou de gauche
la nationale 10 est ce que c'est
vraiment un marqueur essentiel de droite
ou de gauche
est ce que tous ces sujets sont des
marqueurs essentiel d'un parti ou d'une
majorité
je ne le crois pas et ancien à d'autres
un des sujets vous coupe mais qui
pourrait concerner la commune et qui
marque plus l'identité droite identité
gauche y font encore la classifiés comme
ça dans le monde politique
communautarisme
par exemple comment vous positionner sur
sa radicalisation aussi sont des sujets
qui sont souvent accolé en tout cas
cette commune de trappes à l'image de la
commune de trappes correct alors d'abord
il s'agit d'une image donc si c'est une
image qui n'est pas aussi sur des faits
si l'on se base sur les valeurs en syrie
notamment une soixantaine de jeunes de
l'école de l'humour et rap qui sont
partis vers la série absolument donc si
c'est une image
il s'agit de pas de la transformer on a
vu une image du club de foot par exemple
elle s'est modifié aussi par le travail
effectué je pense qu'on a beaucoup de
sujets à traiter sur la commune qui sont
ceux que vous ne citez et qui en
transformant à la fois le quotidien
cette ville quand même temps l'image de
la commune je ne suis pas persuadé que
ce soit un marqueur de droite ou de
gauche mais je connais des gens de
gauche qui sont très communautariser ou
au contraire d'autres qui ne le sont pas
du tout à droite des tendances qui sont
très communautariste et d'autres qui ne
sont pas en l'occurrence moi je le dis
sur cette question là je suis absolument
pas rétorque je trouve même que c'est
mortifère pour la démocratie mortifère
pour la république essentiellement
françaises que le communautarisme je
suis pas du tout là dedans toutes les
questions religieuses sont ils sont des
questions que je considère comme des
questions très très personnel dans
lequel je ne rentre pas dans les débats
au contraire je voudrais que ce soit
qu'on est la pratique pour tous la plus
laïque possible c'est à dire le droit à
chacun de disposer de lieux de culte de
prier et d'avoir
un rapport à la religion qu'ils soient
très personnel mais par contre sur tout
ce qui est un élément de la cité je suis
pas persuadé que ce soit encore une fois
des marqueurs je pense que c'est plus le
budget qui classifie souvent on devrait
pouvoir trouver un terrain d'entente
parce que de toute façon il faudra des
moyens par rapport à ce qu'on veut y
faire moi j'entends parler d'ambitions à
la fois des politiques et de l'état et
bien cette ambition on va nous l'a
prouvé et on va créer quelque chose
d'assez à d'assez important une
dynamique autour de cette commune avec
tous les acteurs qui sont ceux de qui
sont les trappistes aura l'occasion de
revenir sur ces différents sujets de
toute façon puisque vous le savez dans
la campagne dans les yvelines de toutes
les communes ce sera à suivre sur
l'antenne de tv 78 par rapport aux
différents retours que vous avez pu
avoir justement des responsables
politiques pour conclure là dessus on
vous a proposé des choses concrètes
d'ores et déjà alors là ce concret rien
rien de concret parce que je me
positionne pas comme quelqu'un qui
réclame une place et qui va demander
quoi que ce soit mais c'est pour faire
la proposition les yeux dans les yeux de
je me lance en tête de liste d'une liste
et donc je le dis de façon républicaine
à des à des futurs adversaires et en
même temps si le kg c'est le cas échéant
quelle serait la proposition qui
pourrait me faire alors tout le monde
est un candidat que je sache jusqu'à
maintenant seuls mais se gardant un
candidat il ya eu des lancers moi je les
ai rencontrés hier monsieur malandain
lors d'une d'un débat qui a eu lieu hier
à du staff
gustave courbet au lycée autour de
larmes au tour de l'europe et donc à
trappes ton avenir qu'il a organisée
d'origine et elle j'ai croisé monsieur
malandain pareil très très sympathique
et encore une fois très républicain on
va se voir monsieur luc miserait m'a
proposé une rencontre ali rabais c'est
fait othman cet encours voilà je tiens à
dire aux gens qu'il ya vraiment une
démarche de ma part qui serait
d'ouverture d'une part très républicaine
notre part et surtout à il faut qu'on
s'y pas un moment donné c'est juste la
vie démocratique s'exprime lors du choix
arrivera et à ce moment là on fera des
choix et surtout les gens voteront et se
raccordent je pense que c'est un choix
qui devra se décider assez rapidement
quand même mais pas avant mon avis la
rentrée mais septembre en septembre ça
suffit merci beaucoup c'est alors que
tout est revenu sur ce plateau je
rappelle donc pour l'instant à trappes
pour cette municipale 2020 c'est guy
malandain qui est candidat officiel il
avait annoncé notamment sur ce plateau
ce sera donc sa candidature qui qui sera
bouclé pour l'instant officiel pardon
ali rabais son premier adjoint qu'on
pourrait tout de même son auquel on
pourrait tout de même souligner qu'il
est en campagne en tout cas une
consultante pour l'instant avec une
association il va sur le terrain et il
pourrait être candidat et puis autre
magma seront là du côté de la droite qui
est aussi conseiller régional qui l'est
aussi au lieu aussi consulte pas mal en
ce moment et qui devraient être
candidats on en saura bien sûr plus à la
rentrée merci encore mme stafa larbaoui
merci pour terminer ce set 8 politique
voici un deuxième module consacré aux
élections européennes rencontre cette
fois ci avec benoît hamon tête de liste
génération
[Musique]
il ya plein de raisons moi je dis
j'affirme que génération prend au
sérieux cette élection et on la prend au
sérieux la plusieurs manières d'abord on
a un programme politique a été élaboré
au niveau européen c'est déjà
opérationnels dès le 27 mai les
lendemains des élections européennes
deuxièmement on dit nous allions nous ce
sera à gauche et seulement à gauche avec
les écologistes
enfin on a un candidat la présence de la
commission européenne yannis varoufakis
l'ancien ministre grec
on annonce donc la couleur aujourd'hui
l'europe l'est surtout pas social du
tout je prends un exemple très clair que
je n'ai qu'une minute à l'autre ligue
européenne ce sera un moyen de tirer les
législations vers le haut sauf qui a
deux propositions celle de la république
en marge
sauf que le smig européen qui proposait
50 % du salaire médian qu'est ce que ça
veut dire pour la france par exemple que
le smic se situerait à 880 euros
donc ce sera une cible sans doute qu'il
n'est évidemment ils ne descendront pas
mais que le patronat utilisera pour dire
vous voyez vous prenez partout tiger 50%
du salaire médian de caen france et 880
euros ça veut donc dire qu'on a un smic
beaucoup trop cher nous propose 60 % du
salaire moyen
ça veut dire 1350 euros est impossible
non
[Musique]
la droite mais aussi l'extrême droite
mais également il n'y a pas que la
gauche
la question que doivent se poser les
électeurs c'est qui sommes-nous sûrs
qu'il respectera une fois parlementaire
entre les engagements qu'il a pris à
part et qui sommes-nous sûrs que la
boussole qui proposera ma montrera le
nord parce que l'aiguillé censée montrer
le nord en clair quel est le vote 100 %
à gauche 100% écologistes dont on ne
doute pas qu'une fois élue au parlement
européen il respectera les engagements
en privant les citoyens
je pense que la garantie est la plus
solide et la plus fidèle ces générations
qu'ils offrent aujourd'hui fin de ce
numéro on se retrouve le mois prochain
sur tv 78 et bien sûr l'actualité
politique est à suivre au quotidien dans
notre journal à bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]